le ministre québécois du travail et de
l'immigration le front de libération du
québec
organisée et armée ministre labour
serait excellent
j'en étais à mes premières amours il ya
laissant filer me sentais observés mais
sans nécessairement en est très timide
et on sent bien qu'on est dans un état
de choc dans un pays où ça n'est jamais
arrivé
roy jeune journaliste de 25 ans c'est
sûr que c'était excitant et en même
temps c'était c'était énervant
durant cette crise unique de l'histoire
du canada moderne
les journalistes sont très rapidement
devenus des acteurs en particulier ceux
de certaines stations de radio privées
à montréal on savait un coup de feu et
bien on allait chercher les communiquer
on avait le droit de les lire et les
policiers les prenaient ensuite prenait
l'original on faisait des photocopies et
si radio la station radiophonique s'est
cassé le montréal vient de recevoir un
troisième communiqué émis par le front
de libération du québec qui les grosses
caméras aucun trait en horrible ce qui
est un précédent donc était plus ou
moins du rdi avant le temps alors ce
serait presque jour et nuit on pensait
le nono journée l'eau nous nous avons
midi le soir et la vidéo qu'est ce que
mon père faisait ce qui met un manifeste
communiqué dans la poubelle et appeler
jean la radio l'oeil se lançait pour
aller chercher le communiqué c'est l'ex
rose fils du feu liste paul rose a
réalisé un documentaire sur cette crise
recherche paul rose il est âgé de 27 ans
son père lui a raconté qu'il contactait
à tour de rôle les deux principales
stations de radio qui se disputaient le
marché de montréal pour s'assurer d'une
diffusion rapide de ces messages qui met
un manifeste soit communiquée dans la
poubelle et appelait jean la radio plus
il se lançait pour aller chercher le
communiqué qui avait tellement pas que
ça soit l'autre compétiteurs qui lit le
communiqué avant eux qui passait pas par
la police dont il est directement on
est ce que radio-canada on obtenait ses
communiqués lors il semble que le roi
pas obtenu non il n'est pas chez nous il
s'éveille savais quand même qu'avec les
puissants de télévision des loques
il y avait le pouvoir de la télévision
des communications de la radio alors ça
fait simplement la sphère de ceux qui
étaient derrière sens afin de sauver si
possible la vie de l'attaché commercial
de grande bretagne
mais ce jeans rich iott crasse nous
faisons lecture intégrale du manifeste
du front de libération du québec
c'est ce que ça a été la plus grande
victoire de la crise d'octobre c'est la
lecture du manifeste
le front de libération du québec n'est
pas le messie ni un robin des bois des
temps modernes
les gens se sont reconnus dans les
propos c'est un langage populaire et il
mettait la lumière sur la réalité de
personnes exploitées les ouvriers
quelque chose qu'on n'entendait jamais à
la radio aux quatre coins du québec sq
on a osé traiter avec dédain de lancer
french et d'alcoolique le fameux
manifeste du flq présenté à la
télévision de radio canada avait d'abord
été lu à la radio une journée plus tôt
le front de libération du québec n'est
pas un mouvement d'agression mais la
réponse à une agression celle organisée
par la haute finance
le journaliste de ces cas-ci louis
fournier l'avait déjà en sa possession
le flq lui avait envoyé le document par
taxi à sa résidence
alors là lui patron de 5 à 6 ans dit si
radio canada accepte de le publier
si le gouvernement dit à radio canada
diffusé mais nous on peut excuser assez
cassé
les policiers qui sont présentés chez
moi ils étaient munis d'un mandat de
perquisition vers balmont il vibre en
othe perquisitions et d'arrestations
deux jours après la lecture du manifeste
du flq la radio le journaliste louis
fournier est arrêté et détenu pendant
quatre heures au quartier général de la
police de montréal
comme par hasard la veille où elle y
était le premier à lire sur les ondes de
ces cas c'est le manifeste a fait le cul
de l'avant avec ça en fait mon genre
si on m'avait demandé ces documents à
l'eau peut-être beau dimanche les aurait
remis ils sont arrivés chez nous et là
vraiment comme des comme des policiers
locaux comme on voit dans les films très
très brutal très dur et je pensais à ça
mais ça me trouble dans paris
les événements dramatiques s'enchaînent
le gouvernement fédéral envoie l'armée
dans les rues de montréal le 15 octobre
le lendemain la police je procède à des
arrestations par centaines sans mandat
environ 400 personnes ont été arrêtées
la loi sur les mesures de guerre a été
promulguée au cours de l'année comme
journaliste
évidemment je ne pouvais pas moins
dénoncé ça mais il y avait assez cassé
il y avait des gens qui étaient
éditorialistes y avait des gens qui
étaient comme ce parce qu'on s'en est
pas privé n'ont plus assez klm de
condamner cette loi là on a compris à
partir de ce moment là l'importance de
l'information de l'information plus
fouillé le journalisme market et
peut-être mais à ce moment là ici au
québec communiqué accompagné d'une
lettre adressée de la main de monsieur
pierre m'apporte adressée à monsieur
bourassa
je crois que radieux parade a fait un
travail considérable de couverture de la
crise d' analyse aussi à radio canada le
service de l'information est alors
dirigée par marc thibault selon ses
anciens collègues
il agit comme rempart face aux pressions
politiques et lui et nous a dit vous
allez faire votre travail
on a un travail à faire nous ne sommes
pas des provocateurs et vous allez le
faire selon les règles de l'éthique est
ce que ça impliquait selon vous une
sorte de résistance aux pressions du
fédéral c'est ça que vous tenez bien sûr
c'était ça 10h ce soit un début
n'ont pas répondu favorablement aux
cette condition a vécu
munichoise et puis on a eu pas mal de
l'année beaucoup de liberté évidemment
surveiller tout son usuelle
c'est entendu on sentait probablement
c'est peut-être la direction devait
peut-être plus de pression qui venait
d'ailleurs d'un peu plus haut dans un
endroit qui s'appelait ottawa en
particulier ça ça me semble assez
évident cependant il y avait des
restrictions il y avait un avocat qui
devait en régie parce qu'il y avait des
mots dans la façon dont la loi était
dépassé il y avait des mots qui était
séditieux on n'avait pas le droit de
prononcer
mon effectué bien sûr le mot terroriste
le mot aux révolutionnaires je me
souviens plus lier un certain nombre de
monde nous retournons à saint-hubert
d'où nous parle notre collègue michel
st-louis
je m'en souviens de ces des choses dont
je vais me souvenir toute ma vie
j'écoutais michel st-louis à ces cas
c'est d'écrire ça et puis c'était
épouvantable qu'on a vécu ça chez nous
dans ce message il était indiqué que
l'on retrouverait le cadavre de pierre
laporte dans une automobile chevrolet
voici normand maltais dans les heures
qui suivent un dérapage aux journalistes
que majeure survienne
les autorités policières vient de
confirmer il y à quelques instants à
peine la mort des deux otages qui
avaient été kidnappés le 1er corps
découverts a été celui du ministre
monsieur pierre laporte un autre cadavre
celui de monsieur james richard cross la
radio s'est cassé annoncé à tort la mort
du diplomate britannique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout au long de cette crise un journal
se démarquent les éditorialistes du
devoir dont le directeur kurde rhein
exhorte les gouvernements à négocier
avec le flq mois souviens j'avais écrit
un des textes il ya plusieurs conditions
posées au flq y en a quelques uns qui
sont inacceptables mais y en a d'autres
qu'on devrait examiner clautre à une est
alors régulièrement consulté par
certains dirigeants politiques
celui qu'on surnomme le pape se pose
même en négociateur il organise une
rencontre avec l'avocat du flq robert
lemieux cas les autorités der heijden
lui explique-t-elle la chose est
sérieuse il faut ouvrir la porte à des
négociations et non au report avoir un
ultimatum les attaches fonds vont y
passer
les gouvernements acceptent ou n'accepte
pas fini le paternalisme l'est peut-être
et les promesses close ryan contacte
ensuite le gouvernement fédéral le
conseiller du premier ministre pierre
trudeau marc lalonde lui répond nous
avons des informations incriminantes
contre l'avocat le mieux on ne va pas
négocier avec lui on a déduit que ottawa
va suivre mais faut pas rater la ligne
dure dans le métier
le devoir exprime ensuite sur nos
positions pour recours à la loi sur les
mesures de guerre dans les jours qui
suivent une rumeur provenant d'ottawa
est publiée dans un journal torontois
claude ryan serait en train de
s'associer avec le souverainiste rené
lévesque et des chefs syndicaux pour
former un gouvernement parallèle au
québec
bien sûr c'est une rumeur qui a circulé
pendant des mois des années il ya encore
des gens qui pensent aujourd'hui cave
une menace de coup d'état
si je ne voulais pas faire un coup
d'état et vous imaginez donc c'était
ceux qui manipulent et derrière il ya eu
énormément de manipulation je vous
dirais que les manipulations sont venus
d'ottawa et sont venus du flq
quand tu regardes le communiqué sadi flq
qui exécutent est bien le but après huit
années de recherches et de rencontres
avec d'anciens fescistes félix rose
affirme que l'utilisation des médias
d'information a été au coeur de l'action
du flq
il ya beaucoup des gens qui étaient des
génies de communication dans les faits
qu un beau coup que sont devenus
journalistes blessures qui l'ont ils ont
bien joué ils ont ils ont vraiment été
très habile dans leur façon de deux
dents et communique un peu partout il
décrit la compétition c'est ça mais sur
ont été des acteurs blessures qui l'ont
utilisé mam étant il fallait faire notre
métier
cette lettre est adressée à monsieur
robert bourassa mon cher robert
premièrement j'ai la conviction décrire
la lettre la plus importante de ma vie
ils ont joué les médias avec beaucoup
d'habileté puisqu'il avait des complices
partout dans ce monde là dans l'aude
intellectuelle
la crise d'octobre de 1970 tout comme
les autres tentative de révolution en
europe et en amérique latine à la même
période a révélé une nouvelle facette du
rôle social des journalistes et des
médias
c'est probablement les événements les
plus dramatiques que j'ai vécu dans ma
vie
cette période là c'est casser cette
crise n'aurait pas pu avoir lieu sans
eux
[Musique]
je